so there's my picture now I'm actually
not quite finished yet because there's
one last question what am I being asked
for I mean you know what the word meat
is but what does it mean what is it what
do you ask for when you ask for range
yeah you're looking at y-values you're
looking for how how do I go how low do I
go okay so when you have a look at this
guy you can see your highest value is up
here we just we just plotted that so the
Y value is 15 what's the lowest value we
started off with this earlier
yeah it's negative 8 there are the
coordinates there okay so Ben and that's
how high I can go and how low I can go
it's not a bad thing to say okay I'm
between negative 8 and 15 there's not a
bad way to answer the question but this
is one caution I want to give you this
is a piecemeal function right so it's
got all these holes and gaps so you can
quickly you can picture like suppose I
just changed these um these values a
teeny bit I could easily have graphed
something like this
and you can see just by changing those
values not only do I have gaps like this
but now I've got a gap in the middle
like that and I've got another gap over
here right so if this was negative 8 so
that should be an endpoint and this is
15 in this case you can't just say you
go all the way from negative 8 to 15 do
you see that because these guys are not
part of the range these y-values you
can't there's no exhale you can put in
to get those Y values do we have that
problem here in this case you're lucky
we're not lucky we crafted it so you
wouldn't have to worry too much about
that because you can see this is overlap
right every Y value if you took say a
ruler every Y value between negative 8
and 15 you can find somewhere that the
graph intersects ok
so therefore this our original answer is
fine okay but just because you start
down here and you end up there that
doesn't mean all the values are in there
ok that would be a curveball that we
would throw it to you if we wanted to
see if you understood what range really
means okay yeah
for this guy here okay so let's make up
some numbers so that we can actually
state something here it's a good
question so let's let's say that most of
it was just like the original question
so let's suppose this was down here at y
equals negative 8 and this is why cos 15
okay in order to state the domain here
sorry the range I need to know where
everything starts and ends okay so
because this is a question I just made
up and drew I'm gonna just make up some
numbers so suppose this went all the way
from negative 8 up to say negative 1 it
picked up at one went up to 2 and then
moved up at 3 okay
now I've made this as awkward as
possible because everything breaks up so
I would say from negative 8 to 1 and I'm
sorry negative 1 and I'm inclusive
because I could have got the endpoints
there so that's a part of it but in
addition to that I have to say this one
I have to state it separately so I would
have to say or 1y
- and I don't have my boundaries there
because they hold those circles or 3
inclusive 2:15 inclusive so that's a bit
of a disaster there but really the
reason why you've got three portions for
the range it's not that crazy it's good
you got three portions for the domain
and that could totally happen I just
need to tweak the numbers of teeny bit
okay so just to rewind what does it mean
when you got asked to evaluate something
but you get this mess well you have to
look carefully and say for this value of
x for this guy which one of these is the
you know is the key is the one that I
should actually be defined by have a
look
evaluate appropriately when you're asked
to sketch just go one at a time don't be
intimidated by the fact that it's a long
question each individual bit is very
simple it's a parabola it's a straight
line it's a different parabola no big
deal
and then lastly remember what range
means what are the Y values where
actually it can't exist in this case
everywhere between here and here is fair
game okay